from ingredients to portion sizes we
wanted to know all the differences
between Shake Shack and In-N-Out this is
food Wars this isn't a standard food
Wars Episode we're pitting two different
us chains against each other which means
we're going to do things slightly
differently we're going to be keeping
score as we go and at the end we'll
decide objectively which chain is the
best here's everything you can get at an
In-N-Out Burger here's everything you
can get at a Shake Shack I'm going to
make a case on why I think the In-N-Out
menu is better I've been to a lot of
In-N-Outs I've been to a lot of shake
Shacks but today I am going to make the
case as to why I think the Shake Shack
menu is just better but the points will
be awarded by our independent referee
which should be Harry popping in
somewhere you are absolutely right Nico
to make sure this is fair I'm going to
step in as the neutral referee I want a
nice clean fight let's go obviously
these are two different restaurants so
everything is going to be an exclusive
but we're going to start off with the
burgers The Shake Shack Burgers consist
of the cheeseburger Hamburg Burger The
Shack Burger which is my personal
favorite bacon cheeseburger the Smoke
Shack the shroom Burger The Shack stack
which is a shroom burger and a regular
burger stacked on top of each other I am
not the biggest fan of mushrooms but it
looks pretty good this is a huge
Burger the shroom part of this Shack
stack looks empty like it looks really
empty in there it looks Hollow it tastes
really really good I'm very surprised
because I really don't like mushrooms
but this works really well with the
regular Patty because I'm having a hard
time finding the mushroom in the shack
stack I do kind of want to taste the
shroom Burger on its own to see if it's
any more
obvious the shroom Burger on its own is
definitely a lot more mushroomy but
still I feel like the main flavor you
get is of whatever this crispy coating
is which tastes pretty delicious and out
has fewer Burger options but they also
have a not so secret menu with even more
Burgers these first three are what on
the official In-N-Out menu starting down
here we got the hamburger and of course
cheeseburger this to me is probably what
I get every
time I like the cheese with the onions
yeah then the double double or the
double cheeseburger next we have the
veggie Shack I also want to take a bite
of
this I feel like this is just another
one of those where I'm not really
getting the full flavor of the Patty
because everything else is kind of
overwhelming the pickles and the fried
onions is mainly what I taste then we
have the avocado bacon burger Believe It
or Not There is avocado in here we also
have a new burger which is the spicy
Shack Meister it has cherry peppers in
it some fried onion and a
seasoning I don't think I know anything
about cherry peppers they kind of taste
a little bit pickled like there's just
like a little brininess to them that's
actually pretty tasty Now The Not So
secret menu has the double meat that's
two beef patties you do protein style
which replaces the buns with lettuce
animal style which animal style is
thousand island dressing diced onions
and pickles I don't like
pickles but thousand island dressing and
diced onions let's
go the
vinegar of the pickles with the Thousand
Island and the onions
very nice very nice addition and as seen
before the 3X3 and the 4x4 which is
three patties of meat three slices of
cheese or four patties of meat four
slices of cheese come on
guys you're getting this you're just
showing
off I would argue you're better off
getting two double cheeseburgers than
the 4x4 I think Shake shot gets one
point for having more options I think
selection is a good thing I'm always
tempted to deduct a point from in and
out for that lettuce Burger but I'll let
it slide for now apparently a quad
burger with four patties existed at some
point on the unofficial Shake Shack
secret menu the option to add more
patties seems to be gone now so we're
just going to Frankenstein our own quad
Burger all right I can do it okay don't
look at me everyone turn
around I would never order that that's
just like way too much meat to be
enjoyable right now um
but it it is possible anything is
possible moving on to the chicken
options Shake Shack offers the avocado
bacon chicken the Chicken Shack the hot
chicken and chicken bites which look
really really good I actually haven't
seen a spicy chicken sandwich on their
menu for a while I feel like this is a
recent addition so I do want to taste
it that's a really good chicken sandwich
I feel like a lot of people sleep on the
chicken options at Shake Shack they're
all really really good and I do feel
like this looks more filling than their
regular Burgers it just looks like a
hearty piece of chicken I do want to try
one of the chicken bites too I'm going
to use some Shack sauce I'm a Dipper I
need sauce
always they're good they're just a lot
saltier than the chicken patties in any
of their chicken sandwiches which is
confusing to me if you're in the mood
for chicken do not come to In-N-Out
because they have none Inn out hasn't
changed the menu since
1976 so I don't think they're planning
on adding chicken it's a menu anytime
soon In-N-Out small menu seems to be
working out for of them really well
though they make everything fresh so
probably helps simplifying day-to-day
operations plus bigger menus means
increase costs you made a pretty good
case there Joey but I think Shake Shack
still gets one point for having chicken
options we also have a couple non Burger
options there's a grilled cheese and a
BLT I love when a restaurant makes their
sandwiches with grilled burger buns like
the grilled cheese with the burger buns
is very elite to me and I don't know why
it just tastes really good it's like
extra buttery extra delicious I don't
know what it is in and out also has a
grilled cheese pretty much the only
vegetarian menu item they have that
isn't a side or a milkshake if you're
not in the mood for a burger Shake Shack
also has hot dogs they started out as a
hot dog place so it's kind of cool that
they've held on to the tradition of
making hot dogs you'll notice that they
slice their hot dogs right down the
middle this method helps cook the hot
dogs more evenly I personally love the
split hot dogs I love all the
caramelization that you get but I don't
think Joe is a fan yeah split hot dog I
hate it completely pointless doesn't
change the taste of it at all flag on
the play look at the state of that hot
dog no points for that one for sides
we've got fries cheese fries bacon
cheese fries spicy fries with ranch and
spicy cheese fries with ranch these are
new to the menu I don't know if they're
going to be permanent forever but we
were able to get them today we as a
nation just cannot stay away from the
ranch can we I've never even heard of
like ranch and fries together not even
as like a dipping sauce with regular
fries oh my God no I've never heard of
that I kind of want to try the fry
without the ranch first hold
on it's that same spicy seasoning that
we saw on that chicken sandwich and on
one of the burgers it is really spicy
when
it's so liberally
applied I do think that these Fries Are
definitely better with the ranch than
without it and it also helps tame some
of that spiciness this is interesting
I'm I don't know if I'm fully sold on
dipping fries in ranch but it doesn't
taste bad In-N-Out does have fries and
I'm sorry but this is where In-N-Out
suddenly becomes not so great you can
get various
customizations and secret menu ones the
fries H just avoid them uh right here
the regular fries let's take a
bite terrible also got the animal style
fries right onion Thousand Island
cheese better you can also get asper
fries well done I think they cook them
twice or just make them extra crispy
they're not you problem is they're not
very
salty you also get cheese
fries not bad yeah cuz good cheese on
you also get something called roadkill
fries which is Animal Style plus a beef
patty I asked there and the guy said you
give be animal style and a beef patty I
got to make it myself whatever also
lemon pepper fries where again just you
take a lemon wedge and squeeze it on
your fries and then pepper
them I'm not doing that I'm not the
first person to say it these fries are
not good I like the animal style and I
like the cheese fries because they both
have cheese on it and sauce and fun
stuff but yeah these fries like not only
are they weak but they're Bland and
dry no good Joe you're not doing a very
good job of advocating for in and out
there I'm going to have to give shaa the
point those fries look better it's time
for sauce talk sauce talk sauce
talk sauce talk for exclusive sauces we
only have The Shack sauce the real sauce
recipe is a secret but they give a close
enough recipe in the Shake Shack
cookbook this sauce contains helman's
mayonnaise Dijon mustard Hines ketchup
kosher dill pickling brine interesting
and cayenne pepper I think the Shake
Shack sauce is a really good burger
sauce that just works well with any food
In-N-Out has their own special sauce
known as spread and the recipe is top
secret but there are a bunch of copycat
recipes out there that is what's part of
the animal style and we saw it on some
of the burgers earlier it is possible
the sauce contains Mayo ketchup sweet
pickle relish and white wine vinegar it
tastes exactly like th000 dressing those
sauces just sound the same you can both
have a point as for soft drinks Shake
Shack offers coke diet coke Dr Pepper
Fanta orange Sprite ginger ale Coke Zero
craft root beer Shack made lemonade
50/50 lemonade which is half iced tea
half lemonade strawberry lemonade and
dragon fruit pomegranate lemonade which
you can order caffeinated and you can
also get organic harne and Sun's iced
tea and honest kids organic apple juice
I am a lemonade lover I really like the
lemonade at Shake Shack but what I am
interested in trying is this new Harvest
Berry lemonade these are caffeinated
they have like a few different flavors
and they have all these odd ingredients
that I've just never heard put together
here are those ingredients cinnamon was
the ingredient that really jumped out of
me cuz I'm like cinnamon in my lemonade
that's
cookie it has a slightly medicinal taste
that reminds me of tea but not like a
fun iced tea just like when you're sick
and you're drinking tea but it's not bad
I can definitely taste the cinnamon and
it's just a little offputting cuz the
tartness and then I get the cinnamon I
don't know it's not like super working
well together for me but it's not bad
add in and out you have an option of
coke diet coke 7even up Dr Pepper Root
Beer pink lemonade and minute made zero
sugar
lemonade you can also get iced tea
coffee milk and hot chocolate I think
Shake Shack gets one more point for the
soft drinks they look pretty good and if
you describe something as like tea I'm
going to vote for it we cannot forget
about the milkshakes I love Shake Shack
milkshakes they have their core flavors
that are always on the menu vanilla
chocolate which also has a non-dairy
option vanilla and chocolate strawberry
black and white and cookies and cream
they do seasonal flavors pretty often
right now they have the triple chocolate
brownie shake and the Oreo cookie funnel
cake shake the black and white shake and
the chocolate and vanilla shake are
actually different things I didn't
realize this at first but this is the
black and white shake this is vanilla
custard with fudge syrup mixed all up in
there which gives it like a little
chocolaty taste I just feel like it's
going to taste like a chocolate
milkshake I don't really get why it's
its own flavor the vanilla and chocolate
shake flavor is just the vanilla custard
and the chocolate custard mixed together
I'm actually going to take a sip of the
regular chocolate milkshake
too this one tastes slightly different I
feel like the black and white and
possibly the vanilla and chocolate just
taste very very similar they shouldn't
be two separate flavors but the
chocolate milkshake tastes like I'm
drinking chocolate ice cream it's really
really good I do want to taste the
non-dairy I've never had a non-dairy
milkshake
before no it kind of just tastes like
chocolate almond milk not for me I
believe this one is the Oreo cookie
funnel cake shake it sounds like a lot
I'm I just feel like I have so many
chocolate shakes sitting in front of me
right now and they're all starting to
blend together in my mouth I don't know
what this tastes like but it's not very
good they do make floats too I love a
good float this is the creamsicle flavor
I believe it's radioactive orange I
don't know why it's so
orange yeah that's really good all right
and this one is the classic root beer
float delicious it tastes so good with
the vanilla custard specifically if you
want something more classically dty you
can get their Frozen Custard which comes
in vanilla chocolate or dairyfree
chocolate they really love the dairyfree
chocolate at Shake
Shack it's a choice let's see how the
custard tastes on its
own it's delicious the vanilla is really
really good this is the dairyfree
chocolate custard
no In-N-Out has three flavors of
milkshake vanilla chocolate and
strawberry but you can mix them together
to create whatever flavor combination
you want I did not do that I'm a shake
purist so I wanted to make sure that I
got the actual flavors that they
offer the strawberry shake is so good
that's so good
chocolate oh oh that's really good too
and vanilla you
know don't sleep on vanilla people
vanilla is basic but this is a good
vanilla shake you can also get a root
beer float which is root beer and you
then have ice cream in the menu right so
I'm assuming it's a vanilla shake
whatever it is it's really good come on
going after
A&W I think it looks like Shake Shack
has way more milkshake options but I
think it's just a lot of the same
flavors reused in different ways Joe
seemed to really enjoy the limited
options that he had so I think maybe
quality over quantity but we'll say that
you can both have a
point
starting off by comparing the burgers
this is an in and out cheeseburger
iconic look at that so we have one patty
with a slice of cheese lot of onion some
lettuce bun and a slice of tomato and
we're going to do the same with the
shack Burger top bun our wilted lettuce
two teeny tiny tomatoes and then we have
our Patty obviously I cannot separate
the cheese from the Patty it's all kind
of melted in there and then we have our
bottom bun so so a shack Burger is 162 G
Point goes to in and out if that wasn't
enough it in and out you can also get a
double double which is two patties and
two slices of cheese a 3X3 which is
three patties and three slices of cheese
and a 4X4 which is you guessed it four
patties and four slices of cheese The
Shack Burger is also offered as a double
so you get two patties instead of one
which chain gives you the biggest amount
of fries here is an order of In-N-Out
fries and we're going to weigh them
right now 99 G Shake Shack only offers
one size of fries Fri let's see how much
they weigh an order of fries at Shake
Shack is 190 G Shake Shack bringing it
back with the fries that's the point in-
and out gives you four fountain drink
sizes the small the medium the large and
the extra large the small at in and out
let's do 12 the medium 18 or 19 okay
we'll be generous we do 19 yeah let's do
18 cuz it it wouldn't be 19 right 18 I
mean this looks like it would be an
extra large in most places a lot 28
between 28 and 30
if only there was a number between 28
and 30 the extra large it in and out oh
it's exactly 40 oz
yeah drinks at Shake Shack come in two
sizes small and large let's see how much
we get in the large size this is like
one of the smaller large drinks I've
ever seen from a fast food casual chain
so this is 24 o of soda the large drink
comes out to about a little under 700
milliters or 24 o I'm reluctantly giving
the point to in and out there cuz I
think 40 o too much liquid 24 is more
normal but hey rules are rules both
chains offer milkshakes one size let's
see how much milkshake you get at Inn
out from here it looks like it's exactly
16 oz good for you Inn out let's see how
much milkshake you get at Shake Shack I
think that this is 450 mL of milkshake
almost exactly Shake Shack milkshake
slightly bigger one
point I think it's fair to say that with
fast food people want value for their
money we're going to compare some prices
and assign points based on how much food
you're getting for what you pay an
In-N-Out cheeseburger will cost you
$3.75 that is shockingly cheap a
cheeseburger at Shake Shack will cost
you
$749 okay so the whole cheeseburger was
194 G from earlier remember that so per
100 that's okay divide the price by the
total gam weight which is 194 but then I
multiply that by 100 so that means it's
$1.93 per 100 g a regular cheeseburger
at Shake Shack comes out to around 138 G
meaning that it's about 5 cents per gram
or
$542 per 100 G an order of fries that we
got it in and- out was
$230 honestly they should be paying me
to eat these fries anyway let's also
find out how much it costs per 100 G it
was 99 G was
$230 a fry is a not even a gram can we
just say it's
$23 per 100 G we've all collectively
agreed that we're fine so it's $2.30 per
100 G at Shake Shack an order of fries
cost
$49 an order of fries comes out to about
190 G making it 2 cents per gram or
$2.15 per 100 G in and out does seem
ridiculously cheap I think that's worth
a
point let's compare nutritional value of
items that are most similar a shack
Burger is 500 calories and contains 30 G
total fat 12 G saturated fat 105 Mig of
cholesterol and
1,250 mg of sodium an In-N-Out
cheeseburger is 480 calories and
contains 27 G of total fat 10 G of
saturated fat 60 Mig of cholesterol and
1,000 mg of sodium the most calorific
items on the Shake Shack menu right now
are the shack stack at 770 calories the
spicy cheese fries with ranch at 870
calories and the Oreo cookie funnel cake
shake at 1,080 calories for most
calorific items on the official In-N-Out
menu we saw online that the double
double with onions is 670 calories and
the strawberry shake the regular 15 or
16 ounce is 590 calories now as you are
aware in and out has a secret menu NATO
secret menu so these calories we found
on third party sites so can't confirm
that this is 100% true but according to
smart people on the internet the 4x4
Burger is
1,470 calories the animal style fries is
750 calories
and if you get an extra large strawberry
shake it's
1,180 calories I'm not giving any points
out for the nutrition live your life I
don't
care when it comes to ingredients
In-N-Out Prides itself I'm not freezing
prep packaging or microwaving any of its
food this actually might be the exact
reason why the fries have such a bad
wrap people really hate the inl fries
yes including Chef David Chang who
speculates it's because they don't
freeze their fries when the potatoes are
in peak season they eventually have to
use potatoes that are out of season and
therefore not as good but then again
they're always bad so I don't know about
that theory other theories on why
In-N-Out fries aren't very good include
the type of potato they used and the way
the fries are fried they supposedly use
kabic potatoes which is definitely
unique choice for fast food restaurants
the go-to is Rusted potatoes while Shake
Shack's burgers are made fresh their
Infamous crinkle cut fries are frozen in
2013 they actually switched from the
Frozen Yukon Gold crinkle cut fries to
hand cut fries made from russed potatoes
not only were these fries way harder to
make but people also just didn't like
them I'm not kidding there was even a
change.org petition they ended up
switching back to the Frozen crinkle cut
fries in the fall of 2014 but this time
they worked with their manufacturer to
remove move the artificial ingredients
and preservatives I'll admit I don't
love Shake Shack fries I'm not a crinkle
cut kind of girl I'm mainly there for
the burgers and the shakes but good on
them for giving the people what they
wanted as for the meat used in the
burgers Shake Shack uses a custom blend
of 100% Angus beef and In-N-Out uses
100% USDA ground chuck Shake Shack
Burgers are famously served on Martin's
potato rolls if you've ever been to a
Shake Shack in person you can see like
rows and rows of Martin's potato roles
in the back the owners the Martin family
were exposed in 2022 for backing farite
Pennsylvania state senator Doug
mastriano who was seen Crossing police
lines during the January 6th attack on
the capital in 2022 a representative for
Shake Shack told Insider in regards to
the actions of individuals associated
with the Martin company and their
personal political donations those are
the choices of those individuals and do
not express the values of Shake Shack we
continue to be an active conversations
with Martin to express our concern
switching to another potato roll seems
like a very easy thing to do for a
multi-billion dollar company like Shake
Shack but what do I know in and- out
gets their buns from Puritan Bakery in
Carson California the buns are made by
using the sponge and dough process which
produces buns that can withstand
condiments and meat juice without
falling apart another Shake Shack
ingredient I have to mention is the
Frozen Custard that they make in house
I'm calling it an ingredient right now
because it serves as a base for all of
their milk shakes and I swear this is
why they taste so good milkshakes are
typically made with ice cream frozen
custard has all the same ingredients as
ice cream except it also includes egg
yolks so using Frozen Custard gives you
an even richer Milkshake the milkshakes
at Shake Shack are dense and sometimes
hard to drink with a straw but they
taste so
good In-N-Out was founded in 1948 in
baldwi Park California and Shake Shack
started out as a hot dog stand in
Madison Square Park in 2001 it
officially became the Shake Shack we
know today in 2004 wow inter now let's
got some history behind it that's go to
be wor the point intern now has 392
locations in the US but all those
locations are only in seven states
California Texas Arizona Nevada Utah
Colorado and Oregon California has the
most locations by far with
271 that means 69% of all In-N-Outs in
the US are in California a nice from the
time of filming this Shake Shack has 200
9 locations in the US they're not region
specific the way that In-N-Out is on the
west coast but most Shake Shacks are on
the East Coast New York has the most
locations with 49 but California is
catching up really quickly they
currently have 40 locations Shak Shack
is also available in over 80 countries
there are over 400 locations worldwide I
think sh gets a point there for the
availability I like the fact that it's
available not just on the East Coast but
elsewhere and even here in the UK and
other parts of the
world
[Music]
for the most part I think these two
chains do exist peacefully and I think
that's because they're actually not very
similar In-N-Out feels like this
constant reliable fast food chain and
Shake Shack is a fine casual chain
that's constantly adding and removing
things from its menu they do a lot of
seasonal stuff the Rivalry is something
we as the customers created everyone
loves to compare these two you know I
didn't really think there was much of a
beef between Shake Shack and In-N-Outs
me personally if I want Shake Shack I
want in and out I feel like the two
don't really overlap as far as what I
want from either one that's my personal
opinion so I understand there two
businesses they're competing but you
know I think both have coexisted just
fine both chains give off different
Vibes that I do think are inspired by
their regions In-N-Out gives me more
laidback beachy Americana Shake Shack
feels more minimalist and muted and
modern In-N-Out still feels like a
traditional fast food restaurant yes you
can eat there but the vibe is definitely
hit the drive-thru and go Shake Shack is
for sure on the pricier side my go-to
order usually comes out to about $17
that's $17 for a bacon cheeseburger
fries and a milkshake the founder
described the concept for Shake Shack as
fine casual so they're not shying away
from how pricey it is this food was less
expensive than almost all the fast food
that we've covered on food Wars also we
got a little over $100 worth of food for
this shoot it took them maybe 7 minutes
to fill my order I didn't call ahead
went in there got everything listen I've
had both and even though taste is
obviously subjective I just think Shake
Shack's Burger tastes better like if you
put both burgers in front of me without
me knowing anything about them I would
always pick the Shake Shack Burger as
the better of the two aside from the
delicious crispy Burgers I just like how
many options I have at Shake Shack and
it's not like they do any one food
better than the other I think the
chicken and the vegetarian options are
also great the only thing I'm not a huge
fan of is the plain fries and I still
think that they're better than the plain
fries at In-N-Out so when people come
and visit me in Los Angeles which is
rare because of my personality they are
like I want to go to In-N-Out not with
you Joe but I'm going to go to In-N-Out
and then later I find out that they
enjoyed it and thought it was incredible
TR